[Music]
welcome back to careful boys everybody
we are off the record right now i got a
really important question that i think
some unlikely few have had to deal with
something like this and hopefully they
were able to get out of it
unscathed but my question is when you're
dating somebody who threatens to kill
themselves if you leave what do you do
[Music]
so this
happened to a family member of mine and
i didn't know that this happened to them
back in the day
um
and i was like i wish i wish i knew like
they didn't leave the marriage early on
and all this stuff
and um you know
obviously you know i wouldn't be told
because at the time i was a child so
like who's what adult is going to tell a
child this news right but then now at my
age like you know when when we were
having this conversation i find out all
this stuff and i was like no wonder you
[ __ ] ran away you know
and then it got me to go
you know what you should have just told
him to [ __ ]
let him do it because it has nothing to
do with you oh the guy threatened to
kill himself yeah he was like
threatening like you know if you you
know if you leave me i'm gonna i have no
reason to live
i was like you should have just been
like [ __ ] it that's not my
responsibility
just do it you know like like not
encourage it because that could
incriminate her but just be like oh well
too bad and i'm like that might sound
heartless but really he's
he's manipulating you like keeping you
hostage with himself that's true yeah
you know he's got a gun to his head he's
like i'll [ __ ] do it if you don't
stay with me yeah in all seriousness i
would do it in a bounce house
because how do you kill yourself in one
of those things it's impossible because
i'm like bouncing around it's the baby
baby you can thrash as much as you want
what are you gonna do no dude the bullet
bounces around and then hits you oh
didn't think of that oh i didn't think
of a weapon i thought the bullet goes
through and then it probably looks
no not in a bounce house really
ice skating rink
how would you do it it's pretty hard
with the zamboni
oh jesus jesus if anyone threatens
themselves to do that though
it makes me want to run away from them
even more right yeah it makes me want to
go well please do it because you're
scaring me and i'd rather have you die
in all seriousness
in all seriousness
in all seriousness though
like i can imagine that situation it's
kind of like objectively absolutely if
somebody's been like yo i'm gonna
[ __ ] kill myself you balance
objectively [ __ ] balance but then
maybe it's not to say that person who
does bounce has the mental capacity to
live with the result if that person
commits it yeah i mean yeah and just
like that guilt that feeling like i was
part of it's not even like it's their
fault yeah but they're part of it you
know what i mean isn't it good to get
like the family around like to try to
help but that if it was like that bad
you got to call a professional you
probably need to call someone to put
that person under 51 50. you better
[ __ ] call the suicide hotline and
then be like here your mom wants to talk
to you and then you're just like haha
it's a suicide hotline and you run away
and then you bounce and then you wow
yeah because they'll just be like hello
oh you're not my mom oh well yeah and
then that way you're like oh it's not on
me yeah suicide hotline was already
talking to them they [ __ ] up it gives
you a clear conscious and the last laugh
yep
one degree of separation between your
fault barrier
they were there as witness so if they do
off themselves on the suicide hotline
then i can be like that wasn't me fool
you get a psychologist on standby isn't
that also the suggested like legal
protocol of what you're supposed to do
probably just like tell what he just
said like you should call the
authorities yeah call the police
this person threatened to kill
themselves is what you do you go they're
not safe i thought you're supposed to
call the police and go can you please
bring the trampoline and put it outside
the window
because that's not what they think
john's house we need the bounce house
the fire department oh look at this
all right check this out um all right
i'm not gonna leave chill out
i think we should get some pizza because
pizza makes everybody happy right so you
call 911 pizza and you say hello pizza i
need you to come here with a trampoline
because somebody's trying to kill
themselves or else i'll leave them in a
anchovy on that side pleated yesterday
thank you for game night of course
it would be so fun
that's what you do
you call
the pizza and then they they come from
the crisis the crisis guys come as usual
joe
incredible idea thank you
thank you thank you i i think i would
definitely definitely definitely seek
some sort of um personal help first and
then professional help because i think
personally i maybe from my own mental
like understanding i need to like
not make some sort of decision on
something that affects another person
it's just the same thing you ain't got
time to see a psychologist dude this is
happening right now i'm not saying
psychology but even like bouncing that
off of a friend to make sure that i'm
like not making an irrational decision
because it's such a complicated you
would feel bad if you're part of it a
part of
yeah but they're saying [ __ ] how to
be a millionaire you can't just phone a
friend they're about to kill themselves
right now you can't be like can i can i
use one of my phone a friend can't you
be like i'm not gonna leave you i'm
going home to sleep but i'm not leaving
you like we're gonna stay together
and then you'll be like yo i'll be like
hey ryan dude like i'm in this situation
by a bot and i can talk through it i
almost feel like i make my choices you
make your choices hmm
i think that's very part of you oh
really does that mean is that bad no i
think i think in those situations that's
great for you though like if you can
live with the fact let's say me and you
are in a relationship right obviously
i'm like yo i'm gonna [ __ ] kill
myself you bounce right and if you have
no emotional attachment and then i end
up killing myself and you're like
it is what it is good for you honestly
because like you shouldn't have had to
deal with that right but at the same
time i think regular people who have
like empathy and [ __ ] for other people
like people who aren't computers like in
2001 at space odyssey like you you think
about that like for a second
i i feel okay i'm not as robotic as bart
but i have a different whole different
mindset behind this whole process
because like all right if this happened
right first of all i don't know if i can
like i i well the thing is i could still
love someone and then still allow them
to do it because i'm thinking they're in
so much [ __ ] pain that they need to
leave this earth anyway good for you you
relieved yourself of that right but then
at the same time it has nothing to do
with me in the first place i couldn't
have prevented it anyway they were gonna
off themselves left or right whatever i
just i just they're verbally telling you
it has everything to do but then to me
that's like you're putting me as hostage
when it was never about me leaving
that's just in your own head
so then whether i left or not they were
gonna [ __ ] off themselves anyway in
some other example yeah because there's
projection at the end of the day so it's
really has even though it has everything
literally to do with joe it has nothing
to do with joe that's i mean you're both
absolutely right i just think that
you're also like very you're very strong
you're you're both very strong i also
feel like i feel like while i'm crying
there at the funeral i know there was
nothing i could have done but at the
same time i'm thinking
this might be controversial but now
she's in a better place because she was
in so much pain that she had to do this
or joe gets up on the funeral he's like
i know everyone thinks i didn't do much
but believe it or not i threw a pizza
party
anchovies anchovies on the pizza you
guys hear about that famous case they
did like a documentary on hbo you saw
that one right with the dude who the
girl who was telling her dude to kill
himself yeah like they were together see
that's different because
that she she's been [ __ ]
chipping away
telling him to go kill yourself go kill
you that's totally new that's totally
different yeah you know what's the sad
part though like this type of ultimatum
i remember it being really common in
high school yeah extremely break up like
the just craziest ultimatums and like
it's just like
how the [ __ ] do you handle that kind of
[ __ ] in like 15 or 16. dude i had a
chick tell me she would do that if if i
broke up with her and when i did and so
i did it the day before christmas i was
like she'll never [ __ ] be able to do
it someone's family in
town and then she didn't do it right she
couldn't do it how can you when you have
[ __ ] thanksgiving turkey you got your
grandma making [ __ ] tamales and then
she's like i want to know what i got for
christmas what are you gonna do just
take a bite of that stuffing you know
make all those problems go away exactly
i wanted to blow my [ __ ] brains out
after a breakout break up in front of
the front door of the girl i was dating
yeah because i was like
ninth grade i was like you know what i'm
a [ __ ] knock on her door and be like
oh
you don't miss me now boom i want to
[ __ ] do that [ __ ]
you're in ninth grade like
and i'm not the first guy that thought
of that and then the women out there
that [ __ ] do that too they're not the
first people to do that dude joe goes to
your house and he's like tears in his
eyes he's like because i love you so
much i got you this wire brush easy now
you can scrape me up
oh that's the next level
i didn't even think about that
dude cut to her the next morning like
because
your dad's like you stupid [ __ ] [ __ ]
i told you not to date for another three
years
when you said wire brush all i can think
about is what's a wire brush and then
boom yeah
that's like here's some steel wool
you're gonna need it you'll be like
you're going to need this
you're going to be a lot of this why oh
god
jesus christ cut to their next day
trying to use those but they get torn up
by the concrete
so that never happened to any of you
guys where the person you were dating
please tell yourself no please ryan
please oh my god i thought for sure at
least you would have had like yourself
i'm very thankful i know these scenarios
have happened literally just sweating
now i just leave people
regardless of what they say so i don't
remember what if they still do it what
if they still do it is like the thing
okay ryan what happened off the fire
freeway brian can you promise you'll
never tell a story about me in your
whole life
today's video is brought to you by
verity summer's right around the corner
winter not really had it spring still
kind of summer when you're living in a
place like southern california it just
feels like all seasons are just
different shades of summer and that's
why i like faraday close
because they make timeless pieces so
it's you can get one set of clothes and
you can wear anytime anywhere
feels good you don't really got to think
about it because it all is going to look
good together i just want some good
quality basic kind of like clothes that
don't stand out too much but don't
really get out of style and
verity to me is like the perfect one
luckily verity makes this way easier
they make the perfect clothes for all
seasons baby verity is a family-run
brand making high quality timeless
clothing with modern design and
functionality that's true it's that
effortless style that you want every
time you go in the closet digging out
for what kind of outfit you're gonna
wear today that set that shirt that
dress that feels like you had them for
years maybe it's in a gorgeous print and
it looks like it might be vintage but it
fits so well that it feels like it was
made just yesterday just for you well
that's parody baby and fairies so
confident the quality of their stuff
they have a lifetime guarantee of
quality they'll fix or replace your
clothes forever no matter what talking
about making it easier to get dressed
right now faraday's giving all off the
record listeners 20 off 20
off head to ferrybrand.com off the
record and use the code off the record
at checkout to snag 20 off all your new
spring staples that's code off the
record at faraday
f-a-h-e-r-t-y brand.com off the record
for 20 percent off veritybrand.com
off the record hey man i think our
friendship is now expired right it's
just a matter of time till one of us
start dying around you just never let us
be a story in your life don't speak this
into this do you not want to be one more
of your story you guys all keep jinxing
it bro this is terrible you have one
memory of me not one what have we oh my
god i thought someone would have had
something like that
and that's all the time we have left
folks
you have a would you have a story like
that yeah but i mean she didn't die yeah
oh
no i'm out for the story but she tried
and she's like paralyzed now god damn it
no she's not paralyzed she actually she
recovered but it was uh oh she recovered
yeah she was it was senior year is my
girlfriend the time was uh i was having
a really big fight with her and she was
also having a big fight with her dad oh
at the same time she couldn't take it
anymore she said she's going to kill
herself only if you leave she's gonna
kill her i took that exact stance
i said peace [ __ ] all right go ahead
then what what can i do about it wait
she's gonna kill herself regardless or
she's gonna kill herself if you leave
yeah if i leave you because i didn't
want to deal with like she you know like
she was just being we had her own
problems she had a problem with the dad
which was making our problems even
harder so i was like dude this is so
[ __ ] difficult like i can't i don't
even want to be part of this war anymore
so i said all right i'm out and then she
said if you leave i'm going to kill
myself straight up oh my god i did what
what joji exactly said and i was on
pizza i got myself little caesar's five
dollar cheese really cheap but that's
cheap with the crazy bread yeah the
crazy brand dude i literally
and i was authentically not bothered i
was like fine because i had it in my
head already preconceived that if
someone were to do that i would just be
cold and like whatever [ __ ] it
so that's what i said
um and then she calls me back like a few
minutes later and she goes
she goes this is it
like i just downed an entire uh bottle
of tylenol oh my god and she's like
that's it she's like good job you did
this oh
see that's so funny i get in my car i
drive all the way there it's it's she
lived in west covina like really close
to shadow park i drive all the way there
from downey that's a drive and she's
literally laying in the couch
super white why don't you call the club
i called i did i did call the cops i met
him there the fire department comes over
there uh
they had to uh they they induced
vomiting or something yeah exactly we
had to i went with them to the hospital
where they they have to like force
feeder like tar
it's like it's like it's like thick
black tar holy [ __ ] to pump her stomach
out whoa and so like i'm with her like
this and it's like my [ __ ] whole
coldness that i thought i had you don't
[ __ ] have that when you're in this
position i'm gonna tell you right now
you can be the coolest [ __ ] and
once they actually do it in front of you
and they're basically dying you don't
have well then that would mean you're a
sociopath
exactly exactly because it's real now so
she vomits up crazy bread
[Laughter]
meat lovers pizza
yeah so she's she's just they're pumping
it out she she has to forcibly sip it
over and over it's like a tube it has to
go in and then she has to go look it
makes it go in again she goes blah it's
just throwing up all black it's all like
black
when i
i didn't mean really call the pizza
i meant call
the police call the authorities that's
the that's the coals we both didn't know
when you call domino's the police come
right after the noise so it's kind of a
two-for-one
don't get her breadsticks
so when she calls you and told you that
you immediately called the cops and i
well what i did was i i still kind of
retained that attitude of like you
[ __ ] idiot like but i called the cops
rape i drove there at the same time that
like the cops are going
and then we got there around the same
time well you kind of you almost saved
her [ __ ] life
you did save her life yeah uh i mean
it's a little uh cancels out but at the
same time though it's like
well you didn't encourage her no i
didn't how dare she go this is your
fault yeah that's why you know like it's
so dramatic
that she was that kind of girl because
she put it on you but that's your age
too because you said you jumped in front
of a chick's car please
but i was i still had my limit like i
never wanted to kill myself i thought
that was like even for how telenovela
but you took it seriously though you
were like yo i took it seriously from
like you [ __ ] yeah i thought it was
so cool like yeah she's killing herself
see you there like just real [ __ ]
cool because i i had that a
predetermined thing but it didn't hit me
until i was helping her get the [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of her stomach and then i was
like
holy [ __ ] like you would be
dead but at the same time it didn't make
me want to be with her again yeah of
course it never works it may be 100 like
it's [ __ ] done dude like this is
insane yeah but also the human side of
you comes out when you really see
someone on the brink of [ __ ] death of
course of course so what happened
afterwards she um she still wanted to be
with me but it made it difficult because
your dick must be awesome man all of
these like
wow and the rest of the package it's
you know the rest of you 19 million
dollars bro
the rest of you it's uh teddy's worth
eight
i don't know i don't know if like you
guys know this but if someone uh
tries to kill themselves like that like
fully does it yeah by law they have to
stay in a mental hospital for a little
bit like she she had to take it's like
51.50 so is that what that is because
you're like you're you're harming
yourself
so you need to be you know so we were in
the middle of school still like there's
still a school year going i think it's
like like two weeks yeah high school she
was like two weeks two and a half weeks
she had to stay at a mental institution
to make sure she was okay to like yeah
go
during that time like i that's when i
really took the time of like hey like
it's not gonna happen and i think by the
time you get out hopefully we'll both
understand that yeah and then by the
time she got out she was still like hey
like i'm so sorry like i want to make it
work she would come to like like years
later
she i would be doing like a dance show
at my college and i would [ __ ] see
her front row oh so she's a stalker too
did you tell her she stopped once she
tried to come to a show one time
and she tried to talk to me after but i
just i jetted i was like that's the
thing like most people when they say
they'll kill themselves
if you leave a lot of them are bluffing
right and then the people that are
bluffing it's like where do you think
we're gonna go from this like oh yeah
i'll be with you right and then the
people that actually carry it out it's
the expectation will still never go back
like once you get to that part of the
road there's no u-turn yeah what are
they thinking like you're like you know
what
you just showed me that you love me so
much juice dramatic as [ __ ] like that
that's what i was waiting for the whole
time i think so that you know i know
that you really love me so okay i'm
gonna i'm gonna stick with this one
proved it to me
yeah yeah it's something did you ever
tell her you're like yo straight up
you're too old for kisses
she was a bit fine as [ __ ]
when i wanted to blast myself in front
of my ex-girlfriend
i didn't want her back i just wanted her
to feel the pain that i did right so it
wasn't it wasn't even like oh don't
don't leave me i think that's what she
wanted for me ultimately but i think
getting through the experience of trying
to kill yourself having to do therapy do
mental institution i think she came out
with like holy [ __ ] like
you were on my side in a way so she
wanted not to lose it oh yeah because
like you know when you go through
something that traumatic and i was there
with her and i [ __ ] you know i was
watching her save her life
what are her parents there were they did
they go to the hospital or
uh
they didn't they weren't they weren't
even home they're both working at the
time they did later they went for the
mental stuff they were there but they
[ __ ] hated me before that anyway but
but the reason why like they blamed you
in a lot of ways though yeah they blame
me a ton but they should blame
themselves for being shitty parents they
were [ __ ] parents too her dad beat the
[ __ ] out of her and she would just like
be like like [ __ ] up the way like a
guy would be after a fight she would
look like that oh my god so she had so
much [ __ ] going on oh she had a lot
of [ __ ] going on jesus christ so much
trauma yeah it was awful so there was
like i mean it was just a severed and
they came to the
oddly enough they came to that dance
recital too like it was her parents were
both there too so i guess with her yeah
they were with her so i guess they
repaired some kind of like family
dynamic or whatever and she really
wanted to show that but i was just like
dude that's what happened was she there
to say something else right other than
just like can we get back together i
think she was there to kind of
like
it was years later so i think she's
there to show that like there's a new
stability you live the dramatic life
homie cuz you're [ __ ] i get anxiety
hearing your [ __ ]
she did not die
she's fine she's married with two kids
now i that's good
that's a whole new tier of ryan stories
the ones that didn't die but are still
[ __ ] [ __ ] up hey the ones that got
away but they're away from him and so
they're so alive
[Laughter]
pretty crazy
the ones that stick around and ryan are
dead right this is why you're such an
awesome human now because you went
through some [ __ ] up [ __ ] i don't know
why
i feel like it's just like i i kind of
was inviting that i think a little bit
because i wanted to experience so much
[ __ ] being sheltered for so long oh yeah
in a christian household nothing is you
know like there's no bad publicity it's
almost like the same thing there's no
bad experiences they're all like really
as long as your senses get heightened
you're a little bit like that was cool
like you want the wild ride that's true
there's a lot of people we know in our
religion that are white like [ __ ]
george pink dick george from tiger belly
i was so shocked
george
he has a wildlife like that too you got
some crazy stars george was in a yeah
he's in the whole thing he was
you would never picture square ass
george dude yeah cause he seems so
stable he seems squares or is he pink i
don't know what george we're talking
about he's both he got a pink dick when
your lifestyle yeah it's your family
protects you from having a lifestyle
with a volatile graph right they just
want everything to be very safe and
sound and like what a goddamn blessing
but once you get a chance to taste
something that's just either high or low
from that it's like you just want to see
what happened yeah yeah damn
welcome to another [ __ ] up story of
mine
[Music]
foreign
[Music]